Why is RIF technology not more widely known and accepted?
So RIF technology, for those who maybe listening to us
and that have no familiarity with who we are,
you should go to our website, cuttersclinic.com.
That's a big piece of what we do is using RIF frequency technology
to help people with all sorts of things, but live and cancer and things like that.
It's most beneficial for.
So RIF technology is using frequencies to help your body heal.
Why is it not widely known and why are doctors recommending it?
Well, that's a good question.
Well, partly because insurance doesn't pay for it.
That's a big piece, sorry, but it's just the world that we live in.
Insurance is not paid for RIF technology
and so you're going to have to go to somebody who's
using this kind of off label, you could say.
Secondly, there's a lot of doctors that are licensed in practice
that are afraid to use it because they're afraid that they're medical
or carpractic or danceropathy boards are going to come after them
and they're going to get in trouble.
Well, there's a lot of truths to them.
So that's one of the reasons why we are licensed clinic anymore.
We don't treat equal to patients anymore.
We're only making recommendations and care for people
to make their own decisions.
So that's a big part of it.
And then lastly, it's just another thing to learn.
It's like, you know, we get the question,
why don't all doctors understand autoimmune diseases?
I took your course and you really give a good explanation
of different things.
Why are all doctors understanding this?
Well, because it takes a long time to study this stuff.
And a lot of doctors are just trying to make it.
And they don't have time or the desire
to spend thousands of dollars and thousands of thousands of hours
to learn something that they don't even know how to market that.
So it's yeah, it's difficult.
So that's just the world that we live in.
And I don't think it's getting better.
I've had patients years ago say,
I just think life's going to be standard of care.
And it's going to be in Mayo pretty soon.
And this is just going to be so fantastic.
I just don't I just never agreed with them.
And I still don't agree with them.
It's just our pharmaceutical industry
is basically controlling the media.
It's controlling everything.
Probably after I said all that, this video would get shut down.